if the solar system were a barber shop
this would be a close shave an asteroid
the size of a delivery truck is zooming
beneath communication satellites and
over the southern tip of South America
skimming just 3 600 kilometers above the
surface of the Earth streaking at 540
kilometers per minute from the Solar
System's vast ocean of asteroids 2023 bu
was only discovered last Saturday the
asteroid 2023 bu is as close an asteroid
pass to the Earth as I can ever remember
we can't see all of the asteroids that
are coming at us sometimes they are
surprising professional and amateur
astronomers are spotting new asteroids
all the time thousands have been
discovered in the last 25 years most
like 2023 bu are small and pose no
threat but the risk is not science
fiction NASA's planetary defense office
is on constant asteroid watch including
2023 BU as it passes by right now last
Falls Dartmouth anticipates a future
threat it crashed a spacecraft into a
tiny asteroid to change its orbit and it
worked as far as we can tell our first
planetary defense test was a success
asteroid tracking and vigilance are
essential Earth's gravity will change bu
2023's orbit around the sun which means
all number of asteroid orbits will
change around other planets and some
could suddenly head our way astronomers
around the world as I said professionals
and amateurs are scanning the skies
because the situation can change
significantly along with the risks from
asteroids are potential rewards
including mineral wealth the seven year
long osiris-rex mission to asteroid
bennu is on its way back to Earth with
asteroid samples they'll arrive home
just eight months from now demonstrating
what's possible asteroids represent a
growth industry as scientists look for
new asteroids and try to avert the ones
as Hollywood imagines it that might come
looking for us
good luck to us all Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto